il faut d'abord
nominé
on est au 10 juillet
tu vas d'opale roulettes ont souillé
le bonjour je m'appelle marie caroline
bergues
je suis actuellement en stage
professionnel sur saint denis
donc je prends les éclairs régulièrement
lorsque j'ai besoin de mes de me
déplacer au niveau professionnel et
personnel notamment lorsque je prends
l'avion
je comptais c'est un moyen très pratique
et reposant en fait par rapport à la
conduite de la voiture que je pourrais
prendre tous les jours éventuellement
pour me rendre sur saint denis
j'apprécie également qu'on est un
service public de qualité bonjour moi
c'est gérald de 32 ans cinq ans dans le
métier
aujourd'hui j'ai choisi ce métier par
rapport à ma passion pour pouvoir garder
contact avec le public comme je suis
d'humeur à toujours voir côtoyer les
gens donc c'est un métier qui matière
par rapport à ça j'adore rouler je suis
un peu globe trotter dans l'âme donc
aujourd'hui j'ai choisi ce métier par
rapport à ça et surtout qu'on a une
belle île et j'adore voilà voyager à
travers l'île
c'est chaque jour un plaisir pour moi de
contempler mon île
à travers ce réseau qui est le réseau
car jaune comme vous savez on a toujours
une deuxième journée en tant que maman
est donc ça me permet à la fois de soi
de relire mes notes professionnelle ou
alors deux
de lire des livres que je n'aurai pas
l'occasion de lire à la maison c'est
vrai que le bus me semble trop petit en
fait parce que nous sommes obligés de
prendre des tickets pour pouvoir monter
à bord et donc on est vite limité donc
je pense qu'un bus un peu plus grand
serait serait plus étudiée et une
certaine différence entre à savoir entre
un quart et un bus pour ce type de
véhicule c'est que donc les quarts sont
équipés uniquement de places assises et
les bus sont équipés deux places assises
en place limitée et de places debout
donc les voyageurs peuvent se déplacer
dans un bus de boue contrairement à un
quart qui lui est équipé que de places
assises
le prix du voyage est de 7 euros donc 14
euros aller retour
bon je pense que un prix un prix étudié
au niveau de l'abonnement serait
préférable pour pour nous salariés
parce qu'en fait il n'est pas toujours
évident de prévoir la monnaie
pour payer le chauffeur donc à
l'abonnement serait bienvenue
d'autant plus que nous avons droit en
tant que salarié à des abattements pour
ses frais de déplacement on rencontre
autant moi autant les autres chauffeurs
on rencontre des gens formidables que
soient les personnes âgées des jeunes
donc on n'a beaucoup la communication
facile le tout métier tellement beau
tellement magnifique que tous les jours
si j'avais si j'avais vraiment des
histoires rencontre et j'en ferai un
très très beau lee